hey T3 2017 Tony and Michael here we
just played some GT Sport and Michael
there's been a lot of GT games what
makes Gran turiso Sport different from
the other ones uh it's nothing really
sets it apart I feel because I've played
all of the Gran Turismo games really
what I'm getting out of it is that I
just want to play more racing Sim I
asked about if it got some influences
from project cars or Forza Motorsport
cuz I know Forza Motorsport 7's coming
out this year and they really said that
that they're just trying to focus on
their own product trying to make the
best most polished game that they can
fors of Motorsports 7 running on an Xbox
One X what about GT Sport running on a
PS4 Pro that's a good question so I did
ask about that and it's doing
checkerboard 4K so it's uh it's
outputting 1800p and then upscaling to
4K and it looks great on uh PS4 Pro they
also really emphasized the during the
presentation that we saw before we got
to play the game they really emphasized
their work on HDR so they stated that
they actually spent four years you know
making HDR as clean looking and as
realistic as possible because there's a
lot of you know backdrop in GT games and
they also showed the difference between
non-hdr and HDR and it is a very
significant difference and you also get
60 frames per second that's always great
to hear yeah it's good especially for a
racing game where you know you need to
be you know on point with your turns abs
and reacting to everyone else on the
course well I'm willing to bet that if
you played it on psvr it might not
necessarily keep up that 60 frames and
that HDR 1080 in in psvr you're going to
get upwards of 90 frames per second just
because like you have to but there are a
lot of compromises they have to make in
order to make sure the game does run
smooth so I mean it's not going to look
as great there's not going to be as much
Fidelity what I gathered from them is
that they really focus on making sure
the car physics weren't too or one
realistic and two not jarring for anyone
in psvr it's a really cool experience
but um as far as how how great it looks
it's uh now there are going to be
compromises of course sure any new modes
in this one maybe some new events well
there are a total of 145 different
events to partake in uh some of them are
crafted around what's called driving
school there's also rally mode that we
got to experience as well could he use
the driving school for that one actually
yeah cuz we were getting wrecked in
rally mode but yeah there's going to be
a lot of different types of races you
can partake in but we didn't really get
to see anything else outside of the
traditional circuit and the rally races
but if GT Sport is going to kind of beat
the premier racing Sim uh it's
definitely going to have to you know
give players a lot more reason to come
back and jump into this racing Sim
rather than others do you feel like
you're seeing enough reason for people
to come back like I mentioned I'm
already a big Grand Turismo fan so that
alone is enough for me to come back as
far as trying to get Garner new audience
or trying to take other players who play
something like fora Motorsport or
project cars uh I don't think that there
will be enough to wrap them in but who
knows we got to see the final product
and I'm looking forward to it sure well
for more Grand 3 is most sport you can
always go to gamespot.com we'll have
plenty more A3 coverage you can check
out the app for the most popular stories
if that's what you're into thanks for
watching
[Music]